welcome to the tempest this scoutship
is sleek stealthy and with its ability
to cover 13 lightyears in a day
incredibly speedy let's take a quick
tour the meeting room is where you can
make vid calls or summon the crew for a
powwow as you can see it's also the
place to go for stunning panoramic views
of whatever part of the galaxy you're
currently occupying head down a floor to
reach the research room and it's to
auxilary rooms the bio lab and tech lab
you'll spend a lot of time here between
missions tinkering with the R&D terminal
as the name suggests this is where
you'll research new weapons armor and
accessories using research data gathered
during missions and then develop them
using accumulated minerals and omni gel
and if you fancy you can rename your
development projects however you see fin
like so these are your personal quarters
where you can pick up side quests
coordinate outfits and entertain your
crewmates feel free to abuse your
position by making terrible fashion
choices safe in the knowledge that your
crew will never call you on them talking
of whom here's where they get to sleep
it's a little let's say cozier than your
quarters but still worth a visit to
check out the crew info board to see
what your crew gets up to between
missions just over the other side you'll
find the medical bay home to the respect
station this is where you can reallocate
skill points for you and your crew
albeit at a price take a trip down to
the cargo bay if you'd like to check out
the engine core this imposing orb is
based on the same technology as the
Ark's Odyssey Drive hence its ability to
navigate the galaxy at such impressive
speeds finally there's the bridge where
you can chat with Silurian pilot callo
jeff and science officer su v Anwar
slightly more importantly it's home to a
console that lets you set the course for
your next journey and in true Mass
Effect's fashion scan planets and
asteroids for valuable minerals the
now you know your way around the tempest
it's time to get out there and start
exploring
good luck Pathfinder